hello everyone and welcome to the third
day of the meltwater Champions Chester
final series Young sheet of Duda versus
anijigiri and it is the most requested
game of yesterday it is absolutely
brilliant it's one of those games that
remind us why we enjoy chess as much as
we do and it's best to just see what
happens so do that with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to D4 and at this point
in the match aduda was already leading
by a full point as the first game ended
by Duda winning second game ended in a
draw and this is now a third game uh we
have nine to F6 by an H C for E6 Knight
to F3 and now Pawn to D5 going for the
Queen's Gambit declined Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to B4 going for the aragos in
defense C Captain d5e captures and the
bishop to G5 and here it's a very
standard position H6 is the most common
idea and each goes for Knight B to D7
this is the second most popular line now
Rook the C1 do the brings the roof to
the semi-open C file H6 challenging the
bishop to Bishop to H4 and the G5 now
advancing the pawn all the way Bishop to
G3 and now Knight the E4 putting
pressure on the bishop and on the Knight
on C3 and pretty much in all the games
that read your disposition Knights the
D2 was played but the Duda plays Queen
to B3 which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine uh it's just
that the disposition hasn't really been
reached since 2021 unless in uh you know
aside from some online games so probably
the engines improved over the course of
the year and now Queen to B3 is the most
popular idea could be that that's the
reason okay Bishop captures on C3 B
captures and now there are a few online
games where C6 was played but here we
have knighted the B6 by a niche and it
is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game both moves are
basically aimed at defending the D5 Pawn
by playing Queen to B3 you are putting
pressure on it and now Pawn the E3 with
pawned the H5 as the G5 Pawn is now
sufficiently defended you can advance
the H Pawn to play H4 and here you just
want to trap the bishop but here Duda
plays something that means that he
probably had this um prepared at home it
doesn't have to mean that it could also
mean that he just found a very nice idea
over the board but he plays C4 and what
does this mean it means that your Bishop
is getting trapped but why H4 attacks
the bishop Bishop to E5 and now Pawn to
F6 and you cannot save the bishop but
here's the idea C4 was played with the
with the idea of playing C captures on
D5 and okay F characters and E5 uh
anishu grabs the bishop and now Bishop
to B5 with check
and now how do you organize a defense
here uh best to play is Bishop to D7 but
it's not easy to decide on this in a
rapid game let's say something like
Knight captures on E5 now you have to
play Knight to D6 to keep your B7 Pawn
defended and if Bishop captures Knight
captures for example White Castles you
get this position that has pretty much
equal uh the B7 Pawn is defended the
white has the massive Center here black
black is up a piece uh and you will you
will try to survive this as black with
perfect play it should be it should be
uh possible but in the game King the f8
was played by a niche and now Knight
captures an E5 already threatening
Knight to G6 check may be forking the
king and the Rook so King the G7 even
though uh Queen captures on D5 was the
was the safer way to do it uh you are
not in trouble of losing material here
you are in trouble of losing the game
King to G7 and now look at this bishop
to D3 attacking the Knight here uh
Knight back to six now you no longer
have access to the D5 pawn and now do
digest castles so now he's preparing F4
to bust open the f file so G4 and now
Pawn to F4 now again Duda would be very
happy if Anish would open up the file so
Rook to f8 and now Pawn to E4 look at
this massive Center dude that has built
Here pawn to G3 and now Pawn to F5
getting closer and closer to the black
king uh Queen to G5 you might think uh
why move the queen why allow Rook
captures on C7 the problem is even
though white sacrificed the piece for
the attack black is playing without the
bishop and without the rook and there is
no way to defend the C7 Pawn uh the
knights for the moment cannot defend the
pawn The Rook cannot come to F7 so you
either defend the pawn with your queen
or you give it up to maybe at some point
in the game
uh develop your bishop and Rook so here
Queen to G5 he wants to get the queen to
E3 to D2 to go for the attack hopefully
and now Rook captures on C7 with check
King to G8 and now Bishop back to B1 uh
we have Queen to D2 and it's an
excellent Square for the queen you are
now threatening Queen captures and D2
and D4 with the check also you might
have some plans of H3 which will
threaten Checkmate then G2 and of course
if you capture then you get a checkmated
on H2 but to do that plays a queen to F3
and what is this uh what is this uh
sorcery dare I say it if Queen captures
on D4 check Queen captures an E5 can you
just give up this knight uh it turns out
you can for example if you play
something like Queen capture sund4 check
King H1 and queen captures an E5 just
Queen G4 check and black gets checkmated
there's no way out of this King g a king
h8 queen H5 checking j8 and queen to H7
will be Checkmate so in instead after
Queen to F3 Anish says alright I have to
play something otherwise I'm just dead
here so Bishop captures an F5 he gives
up a piece or gives the piece back so to
say to connect his Rooks and for the
moment prevent Queen to G4 and okay e
captures an F5 Queen captures on D4 King
to H1 and now again you are not in time
to go after the Knight if you play Queen
capture Sun E5 then Queen to G4 check is
again possible with the same Checkmate
so after King H1 Rook ate the C8 by a
niche and now uh you there are so many
moves you could play here and I could
ask you to pause the video here but I
decided to use this uh position as the
position on the thumbnail but I have a
much nicer position for you to solve
because here it's basically made in 11.
it's a forced mating 11 there's nothing
Anish can do about it and do that spot
set which is it which is so interesting
because you don't have to do it here a
rook the G7 check was played uh do the
sacrifices or look but you can win the
game with playing Rook the E7 you just
avoid the Rook trade or even you could
offer a sacrifice that would work to H7
everything works here but Rook the G7
check is just beautiful as it's forced
King captures an F's on G7 now F6 with
check and now if you go back King to G8
look at this bishop to H7 check
forces the king to the H file Queen H5
check King to G8 and now Queen G6 check
King goes to h8 and now of course Queen
to G7 Checkmate so instead after F6
check King the H6 was plate stopping
Queen to H5 and this is where the thing
is where things get extremely
interesting Knight the G4 with check
King to G5 and now comes the move do the
hat to see when he played Rook to G7
check or he just said all right let's
wing it you know what bad things could
happen here but feel free to pause the
video and finish the game from this
point on it's now a forced mate in eight
uh with only one winning idea so feel
free to pause the video uh and uh try
and crack this one while I give you a
few seconds
foreign
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the only
winning move in the position and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to F5 that's the stuff
uh now the black king has no squares and
Black's only move is to accept the queen
captured with the Knight so Knight
captures on F5 was played now comes Rook
captures on F5 and now uh there are only
two choices for Anish do you want to get
mated in one or do you want to get mated
in six if you capture on G4 then H3 is
Checkmate that's the that's the idea so
Anish of course went back he played King
to G6 but now look at this Rook the E5
check opens up a discovery and he was in
this position unmove 33 that Anish giri
resigned the game as he is getting
checkmated in the next five moves I I
will just show uh if you play something
like Rook to four to go after the queen
you just lose the game terribly because
after the king moves you you get to
Checkmate The Rook to C1 you have to
block and then you just get checkmated
so it is absolutely crucial for you to
find the forcing mate with Rook to E5
check and now okay Anish resigned here
but just to show you what happens uh if
you play King to F7 and that is your
only move with the King uh Rook the E7
check King to G8 and now Knight the H6
with check King to h8 and now Rook the
H7 will be Checkmate so this is the
Checkmate that dude I saw and now I
don't think he saw all the way to here
but it's very interesting uh if uh if
Duda saw uh this uh after Rook the G7
check that he will be able to sacrifice
the queen uh with that Queen to F5 move
I mean if he saw this in a rapid game
that's absolutely incredible and for
this reason alone and for you know maybe
not alone but as it is a spectacular
game I will for the first time in a very
long time which means it's not the first
time uh award one of the players the
most prestigious award player could
receive for his gameplay and that is the
morphy head so Duda is awarded the
morphy head as you guys have requested
uh I award the morphy head I just didn't
think um some of the games that you guys
thought that deserved a morphy had I
didn't really think so but this one this
definitely deserves the morphy head and
now Duda is one of the few players in
the world that was awarded the the most
prestigious award available in the world
and that is the morphy head
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I mean truly spectacular we
can just go at uh go go through the uh
11 move combination one more time I mean
absolutely spectacular Rook the G7 check
King captures F6 check King H6 now
Knight to G4 check King G5 and now only
winning move Queen F5 check Knight has
to capture the queen Rook captures now
King G4 would be nice but okay King to
G6 and each wanted to prolong the game a
little bit rookie five check and now the
game would continue King F7 rookie 7
check King to G8 Knight H6 check King
goes here and now Rook to H7 Checkmate
it's really spectacular hope you guys
enjoyed that as uh I mean I was I was so
happy when I saw this game I hope some
of you were as well I mean I hope all of
you were but hopefully at least some of
you uh so yeah that's the game really
hope you enjoyed it I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to Dean Vernal uh
G and I would like to thank ravishing
reptiles YouTube Harry Barton Mario
slimek and Francis air for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day